get 12 weeks of the spectator in print
and online for just 12 pounds and we'll
give you a 20 pound
amazon gift voucher absolutely free
go to spectator dot co dot uk forward
slash
voucher
hello and welcome to the spectators book
club podcast
i'm sam leath the literary editor of the
spectator and this week
my guest is sam harris philosopher
neuroscientist and
now with great eminence podcaster
and his new book based on his making
sense podcast
is called making sense conversations on
consciousness
morality and the future of humanity with
and it's got a list of some of his
guests
nick bostrom david chalmers david
deutsch danny kahneman david krakauer
glimspy lowry thomas metzinger robert
sapolsky anil seth timothy snyder and
max
tegmark a sort of omnium gathering of
serious
thinkers on serious subjects sam you
write in your introduction
that 10 years ago you'd been very
surprised if someone had told you
that now you'd be spending most of your
time recording a podcast
yeah you know i really just feel like a
a very lucky beneficiary of
changes in technology both for my
podcast and
also for my meditation app you know you
know but for the existence of podcasts
and the existence of apps
you know i i'm sure i would i would be
writing and i'd
be writing more but there are obvious
advantages
to podcasting and it's a very different
way of spending time so it's you know on
the whole
it's uh you know i miss writing to some
degree i mean i still do it but i
you know find it harder to do just
because it
it really does represent an opportunity
cost now i mean the the stark
fact is that i reach more people with my
podcast in
48 hours than i reach in a decade
with all of my books combined to sit
down and spend a year writing a book
has to be a good reason for it at this
point and i i think i can still come up
with those reasons but
it's harder and harder and it's just
much more natural to
turn on the microphone and have
conversations with smart people and
reach a comparatively much larger
audience
there is a view that people have taken
historically that
you learn what you think by writing
about it
does the same apply to talking about it
can you achieve the same clarity
when you're speaking spontaneously
not as much that is one of the reasons
why i
keep writing and and why i don't think i
could ever entirely stop
and the truth is i do some writing for
my podcast preparing
notes for certain conversations and
some of my episodes have been
effectively audio essays where i really
have had a
script it's pretty close to producing an
audio book
i mean that's not the majority of my
podcasts aren't that most of them are
conversations at this point
but some of them have been so i haven't
totally lost touch with writing and i
think that's true and the reason to
write
even if it presents a kind of
opportunity cost
at this point is because that is the
practice that allows you to really
refine
your arguments and to get what you think
as clear as possible
and that's that really is what to some
degree motivated
this recent book which is based on these
podcast
conversations and therefore based on the
transcripts but
it gave me and my guests an opportunity
to
revisit the conversations and in writing
our respective sides of each episode so
it is it really
represents the final word on each of
those
conversations and and uh it gives you an
opportunity to take your foot out of
your mouth or
or take the other person's foot out of
there and there's
certainly the greatest possible clarity
when you finally
go through the the work of of writing
were you surprised by some of the edits
i mean did you find yourself going hang
on if you had actually said that i'd
have wanted to say this i mean i'm
wondering how much
unraveling the jumper obviously we
needed some ground rules so that the
logic of the conversation wouldn't get
distorted
and so the basic admonishment was
you know don't do anything to your side
of it that will force the other
to say something else you can refine
your side of it
if you're taking something out that the
other was responding to well then that
has to be adjudicated but there wasn't
too much of that i mean
everyone was was fairly circumspect in
the edits they made but it's just you're
just clarifying phrases and and adding
some references and footnotes and just
sharpening things up what made you
choose the interviewees you did to go
into the book
is there a common thread it did
constellate around a few
core topics like the nature of mind the
nature of consciousness
and some of the concerns around
existential risk you know ai being one
so there are a few outlier conversations
but most of them
are on the nature of mind and the nature
of morality
and that sort of fell out of my just
looking at the podcast that
i thought really went deepest in terms
of
the uh exploring these topics and and so
this i think it's 11
different contributors across 13
episodes of the podcast and have you
found your way
towards these preoccupations i mean did
you sort of start your podcast knowing
this was what you were going to be
talking about or is it
an emergent property of your
conversations
well you know the podcast is has really
become a
kind of a sandbox in which i can explore
anything
that interests me and it does you know
on any given week
it might simply be the result of
my deciding what i feel like reading
next you know i just discovered that
well i can whatever i feel like reading
the podcast
gives me a venue in which to
speak with the author and so there it's
often derivative of my reading interest
and therefore many even most episodes
are based on somebody's book
but you know often it's born of some of
my
my longest standing interests which are
in the nature of mind and
and questions about how
our changing scientific understanding of
ourselves
uh can and should and ultimately must
change our sense of how we should live
and so the it's
the intersection of philosophy and the
philosophy of mind and the sciences of
mind neuroscience
and conceptions of morality and politics
public policy all of the the frontier
between all of those seemingly disparate
concerns i think you can focus on it
through questions like
you know what does it mean to live a
good life what is worth wanting
in this world what's possible at the
level of human experience and
uh you know what are we missing what are
we likely
wrong about with respect to what we
value
you know notions of good and evil how do
we think of that in in light of
21st century science those are my main
concerns
now you yourself have this which i'm
very interested in this kind of
twin track of academic specialisms which
on the face of it might seem to pull in
opposite directions i mean you're a
philosopher
you're interested therefore i i would
say ostensibly at least
in the idea that there is a sort of
disinterested rationality that can get
at truth
but as a neuroscientist every one of
your conversations is with danny
kahneman
everything we've learned about cognition
in the last few decades seems to suggest
that rationality is a lot
shakier than we think it is do these two
pull in opposite directions or am i
am i misunderstanding it's one thing to
say that reality exists and one can be
right or wrong about it which is to say
one is a realist with respect to one's
epistemology you know one thinks that
there are facts of the matter whether or
not
anyone understands them uh we live in a
world where everyone could be wrong
you know we could have a false consensus
about what's true and so that posits a
reality
that is really out there which we can
struggle to understand but the point you
raise is that
there we show every sign of being
imperfect
at doing that right there's no you know
if you just look at it through
the logic of evolution there's no reason
to think
that we as social primates have evolved
to understand reality perfectly and so
the the
degree that we have some purchase on it
it's really
uh you know fairly startling as what
we're able to do and
apparently understand based on the fact
that
there's no way evolution has given us
the tools
that would optimize us for this project
yeah i think we have every reason to be
skeptical
that we'll ever come to a final
understanding of the way the world is
but
i don't think we should be skeptical
about whether
there is a there there whether one's
beliefs about reality can be
more or less in register with it
or that one can be wrong or less wrong
about in one sense of the map
and how it fits the territory so yeah
i'm i'm a realist with respect to
my sense of what's out there and and how
we should think about
what we know and what we don't yet know
but yeah i'm skeptical that we'll ever
have a perfect
understanding of anything in hand one of
the accounts
of what's been called you know in a lazy
way that you might
take issue with the post-truth era is
that
radical epistemological skepticism sort
of anti-foundationalist french
philosophers
have somehow trickled through into the
mainstream and
beaudrier is responsible for our current
political fix do you think there's
anything in that
yeah i think there's something to that i
think the
academy has been with the exception of
certain subjects
in the stem field the hard sciences has
been fairly vitiated by
some terrible philosophy you know the
idea that
as you say there is no real foundation
or or no process of error correction
that is objective or that stands free of
cultural bias or in the current climate
we're even
hearing allegations that very notion of
objectivity
is or is racist or a sign of you know
you know white supremacy or man i don't
know if that
that insane meme has made it to the uk
but that's what's happening in the us
right now in fact the the smithsonian
institute
just said something with respect to that
you know that
objectivity and notions of you know
academic rigor
are just part of a poisonous legacy of
of white racism this is quite properly
insane
to believe just look at our current
circumstance virtually all of humanity
is in various stages of
lockdown with respect to a pandemic
which we at this point understand to
some degree
with the tools of science right you know
within
a few weeks of our learning about the
novel coronavirus
we had published a genome sequence of it
and we know something about
what all that means and how to respond
to it and now we have
laboratories all over the world
struggling to produce a vaccine all of
this will
succeed or fail based on how well we
understand
the biology of viruses and the idea that
all of this is just made up or that any
standard of objectivity here
is um just
the imposition of dead white males on
epistemology that should be continually
seen through the lens of
class and race and gender and i mean all
of this is
madness right i mean irredeemable
madness
it's not to say that race and gender and
class don't bend people's thinking i
mean obviously
they do but that's why we have words
like
bias and wishful thinking and
self-deception and i mean so these are
these are
the antithesis of what we strive for in
science which is to
have a conversation about terrestrial
reality
that converges on something other than
fiction something other than a false
consensus and it becomes
the kind of thing that is is the useful
basis for
illuminating corners of the world that
we have not yet
understood at all right that makes
predictions about you know what would
need to be true if what we currently
think
we have in hand is is in fact as we
understand it to be
so much of what is happening in
universities
at the moment is divorced from the in
the basic standards of
empirical science and and frankly basic
human sanity right i mean
i think slightly back to alan circles
social text hoax
right which felt like it sort of saw all
this coming
oh yeah that was fantastic and as you
probably know there have been recent
hoaxes of that sort making the same
point
you know some of which uh sokol
endorsed james lindsey and peter
bogosian and helen
pluckrose famously performed
various uh gender studies you know and
what they now term as grievance studies
hoaxes by by sending
i think it was as many as a dozen fake
papers to a bunch of journals
and they got published or or achieved
some level of
acceptance before the the hoax was
unveiled and you know that blow should
land
because there there actually are no
critical standards really what in in
some of those fields what you're dealing
with
is just a perfectly hermetically sealed
discourse of
whose very foundation is confirmation
bias
and cherry-picking and all of the tools
you would need to to reliably deceive
yourself to some extent you know one of
the points that i think
the so-called and subsequent hoaxes have
made is that you know if you find
somebody's got as a modish academic
discourse
you can persuade them that it applies to
a discipline
that isn't their own if you see what i
mean you know so-called
found in social text a magazine that
wanted to
to believe that the discourse of social
constructivism could apply to physics
do you see there as being useful
boundaries to be drawn because some of
the conversations in this book
talk about the idea of universality of
knowledge or a sort of unity of
knowledge
between say the hard sciences and the
social
sciences that you know we can say
actually here is an area in which
these conversations about power and
framing
are up for grabs and there are areas of
science and knowledge areas of knowledge
you know maybe sort of areas of quite
hard philosophy
that actually you know this just doesn't
apply it's category error well i think
there are different
ways of speaking you know
in different disciplines and i'm not
suggesting that
all of those ways could or
or should collapse upon you know you
know what are arguably the more
fundamental
disciplines right so i'm not suggesting
that
all conversations ultimately are
reducible to
conversations within as they happen
within the domain of physics
so there'll be no time in the future
where we're only talking about
fields and forces and the properties of
particles and and you know systems on
that level just it's just not you can't
talk about
economies that way you can't talk about
most of what interests us that way
but the truth is there's no conflict
between these different levels right so
it's not
while i wouldn't argue for a a true
reductionism of
concepts you should be able to traverse
those boundaries between
fields without discovering that you you
simply can't believe
uh on one level what you believed to be
true
on another there should be nothing about
physics
or biology or chemistry or
psychology or neuroscience
which vitiates what i believe
about the nature of my own mind
you know as understood through you know
the philosophy of mind or through you
know a
a more you know psychodynamic way of
talking about my experience that doesn't
directly reference neurotransmitters
whatever
we learn about neurotransmitters while
it must proceed
in a different style of speaking right i
mean so you know let's say we're talking
about the experience of
love right well so i'm not saying that
we should reduce all of our talk about
love to
talk about dopamine and and you know
various centers in the brain but
whatever we learn about the brain should
ultimately be compatible
with what we believe to be true about
love as we experience it right so these
two levels of conversation proceed but
they're not
they're not in contrast to each other is
that a hope or is that an action
well i think it's an axiom i mean if in
fact the unity of knowledge
framing is true i just don't see how it
could be anything
other than the case because the truth is
the boundaries between disciplines
don't truly exist right i mean what
we're talking about are just
there we have various conventions which
dictate the way we frame
concepts that are born of
you know fairly superficial things i
mean they're that they're literally born
of things
like university architecture and budgets
you could argue that there are
boundaries between categories of
knowledge
couldn't you well but again the these
are imposed
for reasons that don't say anything
about reality as it is right
it's not like you know nature has these
partitions and
the way we talk about these different
topics
has been dictated purely by
the feedback from nature i mean it's
more the result of
you know are developing certain tools
right you know you develop a microscope
you develop a telescope
and you point them in in the relevant
direction
and then you're talking about you know
the very very small or the very very
large or the very far away
and and different disciplines grow
in response to these these tools but
it's not that there really is a boundary
between
i mean there just is no boundary between
specific disciplines in science i mean
say
you know neuroscience and chemistry well
you know
the brain on on the level of chemistry
the brain is a
is a bag of chemicals right so it's just
it's
like you they're just they're
appropriate levels
with which to frame concepts so as to to
say something useful
but as you traverse these boundaries
you shouldn't be blindsided by
your understanding of not working i mean
so i mean just to
take one example if we're talking about
the level of conscious experience what
we what we experience ourselves to be
moment to moment you know the scene
hearing smelling tasting touching
thinking
feeling part of our lives which is to
say you know
everything phenomenologically that we
can point to as being
what we are in the world there's that
and then there's everything else we have
reason to believe is going on
outside of that you know illuminated
space of consciousness so i i know
based on what we've learned you know
over the course of a 150 years or so of
of studying the brain that most of what
the brain is doing
i'm not aware of directly right but
if we think some part of the brain
is responsible for some part of
conscious experience
or must by by by virtue of the way it's
connected to other parts of the brain
be able to show up in conscious
experience or constrain conscious
experience
well then those experiments should uh
run as expected otherwise there's
something wrong about
you know what we think is true at the
level of the brain so i mean the
the simplest possible version of this is
i don't know when this happened but it
was you know it was many many decades
ago
someone realized just studying the
anatomy
of the retina that there had to be a
blind spot
in the an optic blind spot in the visual
field because
the optic nerve passes directly through
the retina
on its way to the brain and it's just
this part of the visual field
that has no photoreceptors covering it
right so
we should be able to see this right and
and so based on a prediction
uh born of a of studying the anatomy if
the very simple experiment experiment
that most of us learned in
in you know high school or or uh
sometime before
of you know marking a piece of paper
with with you know two
a fixation cross and a dot and closing
one eye and moving it
closer and further away until the second
mark disappears
that exposes the optic blind spot now
if that had proved impossible if you one
could not
simply could not find a blind spot that
would require an explanation
that has to somehow get married to
the details of you know nerve tracts and
and neuroanatomy and
if we if we couldn't do that right well
then
you know then yeah then we would have
discovered some radical disjunction
between
our experience of the world and what we
what we believe to be true
uh you know of the world itself and that
would be you know that would be
you know a goad to to further skepticism
but
we're not there right we continually
find that you know the bat the the these
separate disciplines
relate in some intelligible way uh and
where we don't
we're not satisfied with the
explanations we have in hand i mean
that's
there's been a crisis in physics for
most of our lives or you know for
the lifetime of anyone listening to this
between
just how to understand quantum mechanics
and and relativity you know because
they're just they aren't reconciled and
but nobody's satisfied with that and one
of the the things that seems to shine
out of your
podcast as a way of going about things
is that
you know it's a civilized conversation
it's at length and it's conducted in
kind of what what appears to be rigorous
good faith
i mean do you think that's why it's
become so popular in the present
age i mean were you surprised by the
idea that in what we've told is a very
accelerated culture
where shouting at each other is is the
way we communicate
that there was a there was an appetite
for this not
really i it's i i think it's something
that people
more and more really thirst for just
having
honest conversation that is not
encumbered by the the usual convent
conventions of broadcast media i mean
the absurd
time limits where you see on cnn for
instance where they're
they're attempting to talk about
something of
civilizational importance and you see
you know some world expert on whatever
it is
climate change or the the threat of war
between
the us and china or you know whatever
the moment is that needs to be
talked about you see such a person given
six minutes to say something
of value before they cut to a commercial
it's just an insane way to try to make
sense of
of what's going on in the world and
people have become increasingly
sensitized to that it's just that
there's something
especially when you're looking at when
you talk about controversial issues
where people have um you know where it
has more the character of a debate
right well then people come to these the
usual
uh formats with you know their their
canned
talking points and you know they're just
desperately trying to get out some
you know pre-prepared paragraphs which
you know you you know under threat of
interruption and
there's no possibility of of good-faith
dialogue right there's
the idea that anyone's mind is going to
change
by virtue of what happens in that
conversation is i mean that's just
there's not even the pretense that
that's possible right so it's it's a
it's not in truth it's not actually a
dialogue
you're asked to witness parallel
monologues
or serial monologues so people are i
think right to be dissatisfied with that
and
and the you know podcasting is
on some level it's it's exactly like
radio i mean it's essentially radio on
demand
but it it's dif it's different in
at least two crucial respects but one is
that you know most podcasts i mean
some some function differently i don't
know how yours
uh functions i don't know if you have if
you impose a strict time limit on
yourself but
you know many podcasts certainly mine
don't have any
notion of of how long a podcast should
last right so some of my
podcasts are an hour you know or you
know
or summer i think the longest has been
close to four hours
right and it's entirely dictated by just
the dynamics of the conversation and the
needs of the moment and
to not having the burden of a ticking
clock
or a or a production schedule that you
have to slot into
really does change things even when the
final conversation winds up being
more or less just as long as a radio
conversation would have been
right so so like knowing that you only
have an
hour is different than just
having a conversation that that only
lasts an hour
and it's it's different all the way
through i mean literally every moment
is different in my experience as both as
a host and as a
as a participant because it because when
you have no time limit
being interrupted is not a threat to you
ultimately saying what you need to say
so you have the freedom
to digress and let the other person
digress you have the freedom
to let the other person attribute views
to you that you don't hold because you
know that you have the time to
clean up the mess the conversation can
breathe in a way that it never can
in normal formats on television and even
on
even long-form radio so it's unusual in
that respect i think people
appreciate the difference the the other
big difference for
certain podcasts my own in particular is
that
the business model is different and
podcasts are are far less vulnerable to
the pressures you know many legacy media
outlets feel to um you know public
changes in public sentiment
right so the idea that you're going to
come under pressure
and and get cancelled for something you
said or speculated about or didn't make
clear or
it's far less fraught it's not to say
that you can't
you know stir up controversy
inadvertently or otherwise
but it's it's a far better defended
medium
in terms of being able to to think out
loud without
having to be um worried that
you know you're going to pay a an
unrecoverable penalty for it
you you mentioned cancellation do you
think
the idea of council culture is a useful
one
yeah i think it's an essential one at
the moment i mean there are people who
will
say that it doesn't exist but if you're
paying attention
you can see it everywhere i mean it's
just you know i mean just take the case
of
jk rowling of late right so jk rowling
said a few things on twitter which
were construed i think you know quite
dishonestly
as expressing some animus against
the the transgender community
what she was actually what she actually
seemed to be doing is just demanding
that we acknowledge
that biological sex is real
there is a difference between being born
a woman
and being born a man and then changing
your
gender uh with you know surgery and
and hormones and however fully you
complete that
process the terminus of that process is
not precisely the same thing
as having been born a woman you know
with a uterus and with ovaries and with
the full
you know experience of you know having
two x chromosomes
you know if we can't admit that we have
lost our minds
right that is just true anywhere you
stand that is true
and that is being denied by a cult
of activists right it's not even being
denied by most
transgender people i would assume
at this point but it is being denied by
a very vocal
and very aggressive cult so you see what
happened to jk rowling or what was
attempted in her case
and it was it was energetic enough such
that
the stars of the films based on her
books i mean people who owe their acting
careers
to her creative output largely
to i think to a person i mean when
you're talking about the primary actors
denounced her right they
you know presumably felt that they were
under enough professional pressure
that that was the wise move for them
and that is well they may have sincerely
believed that she was wrong
well yeah i mean i i think that's true
of some of them but i mean
you know it's just it was crazy enough
behavior
to my eye that it suggested that they
also felt that you know they were highly
incentivized to
come to that conclusion uh i'm not
saying that it was necessarily
insincere in every case but but the
reality is
that if jk rowling were not the most
successful
author on planet earth at the moment or
you know among them
she would have been effectively canceled
by this effort
i think there's no question that her
publisher would have dropped her
or that if she had a book in press it
would have been
you know swiftly unpublished because of
how much energy this this effort
uh achieved and it's only because she's
jk rowling
that she she managed to weather this
that's an extraordinary fact right
because this is
again maybe she said something that i'm
unaware of but
what from what i saw she simply was
saying
that okay guys let's get a grip on
ourselves we know
you know i've got no bias against
transgender people i completely support
what you're up to but
let's not forget that we have a word for
a person who menstruates
and that word is a woman right she was
just trying to
get a grip on this policing of language
that we're noticing now where um you
know
she was responding to somebody's
description of
somebody's tortured effort not to use
the word woman and therefore offend
trans women in reference to people who
menstruate so
just using using people who menstruate
in this this awkward phrase
and i think as a writer you know
obviously i understand her
concerns there but just you know again
we this is a
this is this is the final trench where
we fight
for the basic meaning of words
and a basic understanding of what's
going on in the world i mean if you're
if you're now talking to people who
think that
any notion of objectivity is white
supremacy
and that there is no difference between
people who were born men and born women
i mean the truth is
i mean i i didn't you know talking about
this issue is not something that
i plan to do but it's just it's just
interesting to point this out
it's even inconsistent within the
paradigm being argued for
from the trans side right so if there is
no difference between men and women
what could it possibly mean to
want to transition right how could you
find yourself to be in the wrong body if
there's no difference between bodies
right it makes no sense it's it's a it's
a reductio ad absurdum of their own
of the most important decision they've
made in their lives right
so people either have to have a good
faith conversation about basic facts
here
we're just going to be hurling
accusations of of evil at one another
and that's what you know jk rowling to
my eye came under fire of that kind of
attitude and it's
it is you know to call it cancel culture
is not inappropriate because these
people are trying to get people's
careers and reputations and livelihoods
absolutely nullified for all time i mean
the people who
are on the other side of this think that
jk rowling should
never be published again yeah
can i ask because this is something that
i'm curious about
and i imagine you've got a view on it
why do you think that
the issue of trans rights which at least
statistically affects a relatively small
minority of the population we don't know
how big it is
has become the sort of crux
for this particular line of argument
if you like between a kind of extreme
radical social constructivist account of
the world
and you know what jk rowling
might see is the you know reality based
if you like or the the
kind of more objectivist if that's the
right word
why is it this issue why has this become
the point of of this front line
of that war between world views do you
think
you know you know i i just don't know on
on some level it just could there might
not be a
an interesting reason and it sort of had
to be something right like
something was going to be in first
position here but it's not the only
issue there you know
obviously race is is a big one and
as a matter of just happenstance
it could just have an especially
energetic uh population of activists who
have have
just pushed this further than than any
other
similar group but yeah i actually don't
know i just
and i'm not this is not an issue i i
spend
much time paying attention to or i mean
literally this is the most i've ever
spoken about it is
in the last you know 15 minutes so it's
not
my issue but the case of jk rowling is
is instructive and and worth and
sobering
and worth paying attention to because
again i i know how this works in
publishing i know i see the other
authors
having their careers harmed and even
fully canceled
under similar assaults and there is just
no
question that jk rowling has only
survived this
because of how successful she's already
been right if you have to make a billion
dollars
in order to have courage you know and
and to be
shored up against spurious attacks like
this
that's a bad situation for everyone else
because jk rowling will be fine but
many many people won't be fine and so it
is with academia
in academia i mean we have people just
tried to cancel stephen pinker
and you know very similar uh effort
and not focused on the on the trans
issue but
you know similar issues coming out of uh
you know woke
activism you know again unsuccessful
but it could well have been successful
with another academic who wasn't a a
superstar
rolling and pinker are both were both
signatories of this famous harpers
letter and actually before i telephoned
you i was going to
i had the impression that you had been
as well but you weren't was it something
that was sort of put under your nose and
you chose not to sign
uh no no i simply wasn't asked right i'm
sure i would have signed i mean i think
it you know there are ways in which the
the letter was not
perfect but no i just wasn't asked and
ironically they thought they could
escape
the the controversy that found them
if they if they curated the list of
signatories
as as carefully as possible right and i
think there's some people on that list
that don't really survive that
that scrutiny but remote for most of the
people they really tried
to find people who you would never hear
speaking the way i just spoke for the
last 15 minutes about the
the trans issue that's quite interesting
isn't it because even then
it's as if they've slightly sold the
pass in the sense that
if we're starting from the position that
it's a disinterested
conversation about an objective reality
the sort of in rhetorical terms the
ethos side of it the
who's speaking shouldn't be important
well exactly yeah and the truth is i
mean that
to some degree undercuts the very idea
of a letter of this kind right like
you know if the point is right if the
argument is sound
it doesn't matter who has signed it
right you're not helping a bad argument
no matter how many signatories you have
and a good argument
doesn't need them right so that so
that's and so i i i am somewhat
skeptical about
the wisdom or utility of of these kinds
of
of letters uh and so i i'm never eager
to sign them i've signed a few uh when
they come my way just because
if i agree with the effort you know i
want to support it in the way that
it's being asked of me but i genuinely i
i should say i generally think that
that um you know it's it's usually
a an ineffectual thing to to do
and you know this this got a lot of
press and it got a lot of pushback and a
lot of the pushback was
only prove the point of the letter i
mean there were people who
were effectively canceled as a result of
having signed the letter right
by people who claim that cancel culture
doesn't exist it was interesting in that
in that sense but i'm sort of happy not
to have signed it but i you know i
think i would have signed it certainly
if if i had been asked one of the
arguments around council culture and the
sort of culture war
trenches in which people fight is this
one over free speech
is there a case to be made that what we
call cancel culture is a result if you
like
of more freedom of speech i mean some
people would argue look
for a long time people with big
platforms
have said stuff that people at home have
gone i hate this
i hate this person newspaper columnist
you see you'd get some people would
write in but mostly they just sit at
home and and
quietly throw copy the newspaper in the
fire
and that now we've got these new
technologies it allows those people to
make their feelings
felt which is experienced by the
recipients of those feelings as a form
of intimidation
it's one thing to think that somebody's
wrong
and to argue that case it's another to
not like somebody i mean think they
think they're not only wrong but they're
committed to bad things which they know
are bad right so you like to think that
somebody's
you know actually a racist and uh
saying racist things because they're a
racist and therefore
you want to you know shine a light on
that problem
and you you think that the you know
exposing this person as a racist should
matter
right that's fine and i think we need
that kind of criticism
and yet what's new about this
is that so many of these criticisms are
in bad faith they're dishonest
on some level you you know this person
who you're
alleging is a racist isn't a racist to
use racism as one
you know arrow in the in the quiver here
you're doing it because you think you
know that it's
this kind of allegation sticks right you
know this is harmful
you know this can get traction you know
that the new york times or any other
normal institution is sensitive to an
allegation like this
and your goal is to just harm this
person's reputation
or actually destroy their career
because you've weaponized your speech
take the present case you know you and i
just spoke about
the trans controversy around jk rowling
right
now you know to my ear i said
absolutely nothing bigoted about
the trans community you know because the
truth is i'm
i'm not bigoted i'm not bigoted across
the board and i'm certainly not
i feel no animus toward people
who identify as trans and
these people need you know all the
political protections they want and
you know i i view this situation as one
where
i would extend all the equality to that
i extend to anyone else to people in the
trans community
and you know there are sort of boundary
conditions and
interesting debates to be had about you
know bathrooms and
this is sort of the thing that that jk
rowling stumbled into
but all of those conversations can be
had in good faith
in an effort to you know safeguard the
well-being of
well-intentioned and well-behaved people
in our society right so
none of this is an expression of
political animus toward that community
but
i can guarantee you for what i said
about jk rowling
and about you know biological sex and
basic human sanity
some number of people would love
to see me harmed for it
right now that's where it becomes cancel
culture right so if i worked at a place
that could be
petitioned you know in response to what
i said
you know here's i was deeply offended by
sam harris's transphobic remarks
on the spectator podcast and a twitter
campaign could get started on that basis
then my employer would have a decision
to make and everyone has now gotten wise
to this that people
can put pressure on employers to
fire people who have done nothing wrong
and believe nothing
offensive really and the problem is
that has worked over and over again i
mean the employers have just
caved into the mob on you know largely
on twitter
right people who don't even spend much
time on twitter
are now sensitive to what happens on
twitter and so it's it's become
an absolutely pernicious dynamic
and it's leading to a level of
self-censorship among
you know otherwise smart and
well-intentioned people
which is also sinister and leading
nowhere worth going
so i can't tell you how common the
experience is of of any
public intellectual who ventures into
this space
and touches any of these you know
difficult topics
in public the uniform experience is of
receiving
private emails you know by the dozens or
by the hundreds
from academics and journalists and
conference organizers and
celebrities and you know you know peop
prominent people in our society
who are terrified to open their mouths
on any of these topics
right and it's just an amazing thing to
witness and the reality is
is that this is something analogous to
what happened to salman rushdie
you know decades ago with the with the
the ayatollah's fatwa right i mean
solomon rushdie was just hung out to dry
by largely by liberals you know society
because he had transgressed a taboo that
you know
no one was thinking much about up until
that moment
but once people saw what was happening
to him
there was just an ocean of cowardice
that enveloped him there and what
should have happened is the very next
day there should have been ten thousand
salman rushdies right so
he should have had company with everyone
standing by his side protecting his
freedom of speech and their own
and that solidarity would have nullified
his problem right i mean that would
he would not have had to have gone into
hiding for 10 years
in response to that fatwa and and we're
witnessing a similar thing it's not
where fatwas are being you know real fat
you know
islamic fatwas are being issued but but
there's something
analogous to the analogous to that it's
a quasi-religious
hysteria that is targeting people and
many people are going under and it's
scary to watch
to move slightly sideways i mean there
are of course
good arguments from principal for you
know
very very wide remit on free speech but
the sort of pragmatic argument has
always been
if speech is as free as as possible
consistent with
i guess you know injunctions against
incitement violence and so forth
good ideas will drive bad ideas out
now how much as our media environment
changes
do you feel that's something that has
the status of a kind of
absolute truth that you can state with
confidence and how much does it feel
like an article of faith
well i i do worry that within any
time frame it may not in fact be
true right so i i think ultimately
it is is true or or
effectively true that good ideas
win but there but there is a difference
between
and we might distinguish the truth of an
idea
and the the fitness of an idea right and
you know fitness in a very much in a
darwinian sense you know the
an idea a meme can survive
competition with all its rivals and it
is
an unhappy fact about us that
certain very bad ideas and and obviously
false
ones are seemingly very fit
for competition with their rivals and
they they spread well
they are readily believed or at least
endorsed
and they're hard to eradicate that's a
sobering fact about
human discourse it is an article of
faith on some level i think it's
ultimately very likely to be true but
the conversation has to
continue long enough to to enforce that
truth or
to make it possible for a sufficient
number of collisions to happen
such that that bad ideas are exposed as
bad
right or or internally inconsistent
right
or uh inconsistent with what we
subsequently learn to be true about the
world or about ourselves right so i just
think i mean
the reason why good ideas or you know or
you know factual
statements have to be
fitter in the end is because they you
know by definition
only they will survive repeated
collisions with
new facts and new arguments and and new
evidence as it comes in
right i mean that you know that's that's
what it is to to
error correct right so what we need the
reason why
a a fairly complete
commitment to freedom of speech however
in delicate it makes sense is
conversation is the only tool we have
to produce that error correction
right it's the only method we have to
continually
stress test our beliefs and see what
survives
and this is why it doesn't matter who's
who
wrote the letter or who signed it in the
end it's like
either these the argument is is true or
false and
and it doesn't become false once you
realize that
you know a nazi signed the letter
you we we need to to be intellectually
honest enough
to recognize that there that there are
bad people
who occasionally say factually correct
things and there are good people
who occasionally are are fl
flagrantly wrong about the the you know
in their claims about the nature of the
world
the the propositional content of a
statement is divorcible
from who said it or who believed it or
who was right about it or who
who was mistaken and and we just have to
be
able to make those distinctions
otherwise there's again
it's like it's not just culture and
politics that depend on these
distinctions it's basic human sanity
yeah
there's a very interesting discussion in
in one of these conversations
which surprised me your response it's a
thought experiment
and you'll be able to tell me who who
came up with it about an
urn of invention whereby
you know humankind is forgive me if i'm
misrepresented it's sort of
randomly pulling these colored balls out
of the this pot
and there are white ones which are ideas
or inventions that advance humanity
in an uncomplicated way gray ones which
have both costs and benefits
and there is what if somewhere in that
urn there's a black one
which having been invented
can't be uninvited and essentially poses
as an existential threat i think is that
the right
way of understanding it yeah yeah that's
an example you light up that's from nick
bostrom
nick bostrom who's a philosopher at the
university of oxford and
quite a a creative thinker and yeah so
it's a great
analogy and it he he uses it to describe
you know scientific inventions and you
know
and new technologies mostly but it it
would apply to really any
idea that can't be unthought or
uninvented right you know so so yeah
it's
it's quite pot we've been pulling white
and gray balls out
of this urn and as you say so you know
the gray balls are
have a kind of dual character they can
be incredibly
uh useful and and um
and uh you know help us do a variety of
things
i mean it's a gray ball might be the
internet it might be
you know our ability to uh produce
nuclear
power by splitting the atom but
obviously there's a good and bad to
these things but
so nick is imagining that it's at least
conceivable that
there's a at least you know
some number of black balls in the the
urn of invention which
which is to say that there are things
that we could discover
with the mere discovery of which it
would be synonymous
with human extinction in the end one
example he gives is
what if it just proved to be the case
that's
you know initiating the nuclear chain
reactions split in the atom
nuclear fission once we discovered it it
was
trivially easy to do it required nothing
more than you know taking two pieces of
glass
and a handful of sand and putting them
together and you know you know sticking
them in a microwave oven say right i
mean just something that anyone could
once they once we
once the knowledge got out about how to
do this
any suicidal maniac could blow up a city
with zero training right if we lived in
that world
where where that was was in fact
the way things worked well then the game
would be over
right we would you know a hundred cities
would have been already devastated by
a nuclear blast because it you just
don't need that many crazy suicidal
people
but it's the second stage of the thought
experiment that i found so interesting
and you said
you call it turnkey totalitarianism you
say you know it would be moral indeed
necessary
to put in place effectively some sort of
totalitarian system to prevent this from
happening
yeah so that that again that's that
doesn't originate with me that's nick's
argument and again just just imagine
what happened what if we
discover some property of matter such
that you could initiate a
city annihilating explosion
based on doing almost nothing right
you know just literally just you just
need the information about how to do it
and you can walk into your
kitchen and do it right if that's the
way atoms behave
well then in order to survive in the
only
political regime compatible with human
survival in that case very likely
is for some you know fairly orwellian
strata of of government to know what
you're doing with your hands at all
times
we can't leave you alone with your hands
for more than
30 seconds because some number of people
given that freedom would uh
destroy a whole city every day of the
year
right going forward so nick is not
trying to celebrate
the the prospects of totalitarianism
he's just saying it's possible that we
live in a world where
we could discover something so dangerous
that it would force a complete change
of political expectation and aspiration
on us
overnight because of just how dangerous
this knowledge is and just how
uncontainable it is we could literally
open pandora's box
and be faced with an emergency that
would
never go away right his underlying point
here is that
we practice science without
any foresight that this is the situation
we might be in right
no one is constraining no one
very few people are even thinking about
constraining their
inquiry into the way the world is by
this possibility so nick is arguing i
mean people who
focus on existential risk as a problem
are trying to build awareness around
this principle that
yeah we just can't keep pulling
balls out of the urn without any
awareness of of the prospect that
that certain types of knowledge might be
suicidal and so that i think that's a
very interesting
thing to to argue for and i think we
know something about
the possibilities here to be worried on
certain fronts
such that we we should be moving very
carefully right i think
you know nick and does it have practical
ramifications
i mean recognizing this yeah well i
think it does for instance with with ai
safety i think it's
you know that conversation has been
pushed again largely by nick
into a place where many serious people
who are doing the work are taking these
kinds of concerns seriously
we have on some level only
one chance to get superhuman ai
right we're going to be in a situation
where we produce
artificial intelligence that is beyond
human in every relevant respect which is
to say more powerful
than we are we we will if we just keep
making progress
and you know the only reason to think we
wouldn't is
some other civilizational catastrophe
would befall us in in the meantime but
if we avoid that and we just keep
building
more intelligent machines at a certain
point
they will be better than we are for
everything we care about
cognitively and at that point they will
be
better than we are at designing the next
iteration of
software and hardware and to rule that
out is to assume something
you know i think at this point quite
indefensible about the nature of
intelligence and the nature of
minds right so i mean you'd have to
imagine that
there's just some reason this is
impossible in principle we'll never
develop
superhuman minds in silico and i just
think that's just
there's no reason to believe that so if
we just keep going
we will find ourselves on the cusp or or
over
the cusp of you know a breakthrough
in building intelligent machines and
then suddenly be in relationship
to something more powerful than
ourselves
that will have an independent point of
view and whether it's conscious or not
i'll
leave that aside you know it might in
fact be another conversation yeah
yeah i mean that the lights the lights
might not be on at all but
the power of its intelligence will be
indisputable
and what we don't want at that point is
to find ourselves in negotiation
with something smarter than ourselves
who may develop its own
goals that we can't foresee
and that we haven't tethered to our own
aspirations effectively enough such that
its autonomy is is now at odds with our
own
well-being right and and we don't again
we don't want to be
in a situation where we're saying okay
could you stop doing that that's not you
know that's not
exactly what we were hoping for again
we're now negotiating
rather than in a position where we can
simply turn something off right and
nick more than anyone in his book super
intelligence
he sketched out this terrain in
broad strokes very effectively and very
vividly and it's a fantastic book i
recommend people
read it it's um and it i mean
i mean lest you think it's these are
these problems
are just by definition you know
fanciful or or will be just we'll just
be we'll just know how to solve them
when they arrive
i think you're cured of that by getting
into this literature
and nick's book is a great place to
start is it conceivable to you
again as a thought experiment that a
black ball could emerge
which isn't a sort of scientific
invention but which is an idea
or a form of speech or some other sort
of meme
that would necessitate the same sort of
totalitarian reaction for our own safety
i mean
do you see speech as a totally separate
category from if you like
technological invention
you'd have to spell out what the power
of
this idea would be i mean i think
there's some
spectacularly bad ideas out there that
are very dangerous
right that need to be criticized and
having unconstrained speeches is you
know
is your your cognitive and social immune
system
in action there so i mean i think we
need to
to be able to criticize some of the you
know the ideas that have come up even
thus far in this conversation uh
ideas about race and gender and i think
these are
there's a kind of moral panic and you
know even hysteria
brewing here which i think is socially
very damaging and politically very
dangerous
and i think it's you know it's the kind
of thing that
if left to do its mad work
unchecked can produce its own spectrum
of you know very damaging effects but
could also produce a a a very dangerous
counter reaction right i i largely think
of don you know the the presidency of
donald trump
at least in part as a reaction to
what has been happening on the left and
the influence of the far left
on even very mainstream uh institutions
on you know on
on academia and on on mainstream
journalism
and the the distrust of institutions
the almost ubiquitous uh distrust
institutions now is to a significant
degree
a measure of what the left has done to
these institutions
and i consider myself you know very much
a liberal
on you know almost every point but
the distinction between you know real
liberalism
and what has happened on the far left
has
become increasingly excruciating
the counter-reaction to all of this is
um
is something that i worry a lot about
and yeah as you probably know i'm
i consider myself as
committed a critic of donald trump as as
really anyone on earth
there's almost nothing to say uh
critical of the man that is that proves
an exaggeration
but you know that said so much of the
left's
criticism of him also manages to be in
bad faith
right so for instance while i do not
doubt that he's a racist
many of the allegations against him
uh alleging his racism are obviously
absurd
the left is so badly calibrated in its
attacks against the right
you know finding nazis everywhere even
where they can't possibly exist
that it's um it's it's so unhelpful
that i think it it energizes its own
it's its counter response
if we happen to live in a universe where
you know to
my horror we wind up with four more
years of of donald trump
which i you know i consider you know
something like an existential threat to
at least to our democracy
i will largely blame the far left for
that
right and it's dishonesty and it's panic
and it's
absolutely bonkers calls to you know
abolish the police right in the united
states right even in the highest crime
parts of our cities right it's just it's
completely nuts and it's exactly the
kind of thing that could get trump
reelected again he may be too far gone
given his inept response to the coveted
pandemic but
if anything is going to get him
re-elected it will be that kind of
craziness and again so to my eye the
leftist seems to be doing everything
it can to get trump reelected rather
than doing
the sane and prudent things that it
could do to
to block his his chances i worry about
both sides of the political spectrum
here
but if you're talking about an idea that
is so bad
that the mere thinking of it could get
us all to
annihilate ourselves it would have to be
again i mean for that to be true it
would have to be
completely impervious to
the pressures of criticism and i just i
you know
i think criticism is stronger than that
i can't see what the shape of that idea
could possibly be i mean it's a little
bit like alleging that there is the
money python routine
that you know there's a joke so funny
that it you know the mere hearing of it
proves
lethal right so you just have to tell
this joke on the battlefield and watch
it spread
you know it's a little bit like that i
don't know i don't i can't imagine a
joke
quite that funny we've taken a lot of
your time already sam harris thank you
very much
indeed it's been a pleasure talking to
you
[Music]
get 12 weeks of the spectator in print
and online
for just 12 pounds and we'll give you a
20 pound
amazon gift voucher absolutely free
go to spectator dot co dot uk forward
slash
voucher